so men are saying like we like it
natural we like a natural but they're
gravitating right towards a lot of
ladies who are nothing close to Natural
men don't want to admit that they like
it more than they actually claim and
women don't want to admit that they're
doing it for men's attention today's big
question why do women get plastic
surgery why do women get plastic surgery
yeah oh it's for
themselves it's for themselves I'm
actually curious so I think you and I
have heard a lot of the discourse
surrounding this topic and a lot of it's
like you know the reason why women are
getting um
surgery is to keep up with other ladies
or some of the stuff they seeing they're
doing it for themselves to get over
their own insecurities and stuff like
that and I'll be honest with you since
the first day I heard that stuff I never
believed it I did you did yeah because
it's it depends on what they mean by
that is I think that you guys are saying
you're you mean you want to mean the
same thing but you're saying differently
but it doesn't sound the marketing is
off of what they say okay okay what I
mean by that is you don't think they do
this for themselves you think they're
doing this for others and what they say
is I'm doing this this for me for my
insecurities but your insecurities are
stemmed and are are are rooted into what
other people are thinking and the
reflection of what you think you're
doing this for others with a lot of
steps that's what it is we're not saying
the same thing the reason is this the
motivation is completely different what
I'm alleging is that you're doing it for
social acceptance what they're alleging
is that irrespective of how anyone else
would feel about it they would still get
the same surgery I don't think that's
true I don't think that's true either
yeah you're right about that and the
reason why I feel like it's very
different is like if we were all just
autonomously doing these things for
ourselves there would be no reason for
us to be all appealing to the same
beauty standards me and preach are old
enough to at least seen the beauty
trends change from the '90s onward 100%
And I always say this the reason why
everyone's in the gym squatting the
reason why everyone wants a fat ass that
or they want to get BBL is Hip-Hop
Hip-Hop as hip-hop got more popular that
Trend and that thing became more and
more appealing because you can trust me
go look at a lot of the models in the
90s everybody was trying to lose their
ass everybody was trying to make sure
they had no ass they all try to look
like Pamela Anderson and inflate the
that's all they wanted to do so you saw
the change and then you saw everyone's
surgeries and everyone's desires change
even the whole hourglass thing this is
like a lot of the stuff that we were
really pushing through a lot of these
medias um so I've never believed it
because I've seen the way women's Minds
have been changed in regards to what
they find appealing and I'm like I just
have to ask when you get a BBL okay and
you're risking your life to get this
surgery are you just spending all day
staring at it in the mirror and being
like this was worth risking my life for
I don't believe that I just don't
believe that you
look
yeah yeah I don't believe that that's
not what happen that's not let me ask
you one simple question how come you
don't see a bunch of lesbians getting
bbl's every day how come you don't see
the Lesbos getting their te on the same
way for everyone I'm not saying they
don't have their own stuff that they do
but it's normally to confirm to like the
butch stereotype of or stuff like that
or if they're not butch it's to confirm
to certain C if you're not doing for the
male gays and you're doing for the
ladies you still it's still attention
but but but but did you notice though
when you see this they don't have the
same kind of surgeries if they rarely
and they rarely get it too and
completely yeah it's not as bad no so so
like you just look at this for one
minute and you'll notice like yo most of
them are never getting these kind of
boob jobs or anything like that why
because they're not appealing to what
they think the ideal thing the men want
you do it because you see other women
who have these power glass shapes or
whatever get a certain level of
attention or agulation that you would
like to some degree be it from your
partner or from Men in general or from
society in general and you and you
conform to that when you get the BBL
it's not so much that you go back home
and you look at the miror and you're
like no no is the int the attention that
you get when you walk outside y that's
what you like and it's I get it
absolutely I get it I'm not even trying
to say you were wrong or whatever what
not I'm just trying to say a fact
attention is liking attention is not
apply a good thing or a bad thing it's
just a thing and then we could turn it
to a good thing or a bad thing depending
on what it is or where it's rooted or
whatever what not anyways that being
said you like the attention because when
you walk with that BBL [__]
turn around they look they whisper mhm
they point and that attention people all
eyes on you you feel like Tupac sh curve
right there walking with J picking Smith
yeah I I'll say this I I think that's
really the cck of It We crave that
attention We crave that acceptance that
recognition from our peers or Community
whoever it might be and it's okay to
admit that like you got a social media
account and you post semi- regularly you
know a part of that is for that
attention and that recognition from your
peers not everyone's doing it on the
same degree to the same level right and
not every form of it is healthy but we
all need and require attention from
others and coming to terms with that and
accepting it is okay it's not something
to be shamed for now in its extreme
force we can look at it and say it's
unhealthy it's a little bit unhinged
when people are like literally risking
their lives just for people's attention
all the time but I think as a society we
try to do this fake humble thing so much
oh I don't need nobody I'm good by
myself yeah yeah I'm not doing it for
nobody else I just you know I noticed
this more and more in every way try to
type of way we try to see more and more
individualistic as if other people don't
matter when in reality vast majority of
us are propping ourselves even this
whole like I don't need nobody is to
appeal to others to make yourself feel
better than them 100% And so it's just
like yo embrace it you you like
attention it's okay there's nothing to
be ashamed of we've convinced oursel is
bad but it's not like our kids need our
attention we need our attention from the
kids like imagine if like your loved
ones ignored you imagine people around
you ignored you imagine if the person
you like ignor you all the time of
course it's hurtful so it's okay to say
you want attention from people I just
think we all want to pretend like oh you
can't say that you think you lying you
think I I I got the motorcycles that I
got cuz no it's just for me it's a bit
for me there's a there's a part that
there's a part of me that like the speed
or whatever what not but a motorcycle
goes fast no matter what motorcycle I'm
going to get I'm going to be able to go
a certain amount of speed with I
chose one of them is a hyabusa why
because it's a world
renowned world record motorcycle I
wanted that for me because it's a
respected motorcycle you got to admit to
it
yeah I ain't mad at saying that people
this and people people got like
attention it's okay they do they do
certain things for for that absolutely
when you come to my house I'mma give you
the wine pause the perfect wine pause
good alcohol yeah that's better I don't
think it's too late for you but carry on
I think it's too late for you no no no
no don't bring me this you had your
little SX moment embrace it you can walk
off into the sun and the rainbow why did
you bring the rainbow with the that
because anytime it gets Sunny for you I
know it's a little Rainbow get your
lucky charms for
the potato don't worry about it go ahead
but yeah I I like to give I like to I
like to give perfect things I like to
give ptin things because it give a a
little bit more of the Ambiance and it
give a little bit more people appreciate
that absolutely preach got the nice
stuff yeah I do I do but you're right
when you saying that it's it's like a
new TR friend of yeah n is me Kevin all
Kevin all me at night by myself all day
in the block doing me by myself alone
solo Doo solo Doo no [__] new [__]
new year new me stand alone right here
on the corner by
myself fact y that's how people really
trying to tell y it is cringe pipe down
I'm I'm I'm I'm going to give you the
best example of this okay and here's the
thing too
[Music]
that's no that's fire put that up and
here's the thing with men too men
sometimes play themselves a little bit
because if you ask men openly they'll be
like I don't like women with makeup I
don't like women with plastic surgery
but you notice anytime men get a lot of
what are the kind of women they dating
they get the most boobed up assed up
plasti up girl they can find you see all
these celebrities and stuff they're
getting women with plenty of plastic
surgery they themselves are getting
plastic surgeries they'll talk about how
they love everything natural when you go
to the Instagram women with the fakest
looking bodies and these dudes are
obsessing over it or liking it or
throwing their money at it like it's the
greatest gift from God right even though
it's really just a gift from your local
plastic
surgeon they doing that so they're also
setting the signals that are reinforcing
to these ladies that oh this [__] is
desirable and let's also keep it a stack
women do get these surgeries whether you
like to admit or not a lot of them end
up looking amazing and close you're like
no ABA they look like clowns that's the
ones who get the bad jobs you would be
shocked how many men cannot tell when
women have had a very modest boob job or
many modest BBL they they don't even
know when a woman's done a tummy Tu they
don't even know like they'll look oh
she's in shape no bro she she got a BBL
she got the stuff taken off her stomach
and she got to put it slightly in her
hips and that's what happened that's why
her body looks snatched she don't
naturally have that hourglass sheap but
you wouldn't know because you don't even
know what to look like so men are saying
like we like a natural we like a natural
but they're gravitating right towards a
lot of ladies who are nothing close to
natural natural bodies a lot of dudes
not [__] with like they think they do
same with makeup oh yeah I like women
natural a lot of the women you likeing
they got makeup it might be lighter than
some but they got it mhm so men have set
the standard we've decided what's
attractive women have conformed to it
cuz they want that but a lot lot of
people just don't want to admit it men
don't want to admit that they like it
more than they actually claim and women
don't want to admit that they're doing
it for men's attention it is a bizarre
thing that is going on but the truth is
we're all playing a part I'm going tell
yeah that's what I was about to say it's
everybody's I'm not blaming a woman
getting into surgeries I'm not it's
everybody everybody everybody take a l
on that [__] even the people that yeah
like you said even the people that said
I don't like it they end up liking it
yes and you know for some part they some
some of them people look good and some
of them is just outrageous and to some
of y'all it's still look good it's it's
it's okay I've just seen the rise of
surgeries all around me in my local area
I've just seen so many people who I used
to recognize who I'm like you're
somebody that I used to
[Music]
know yeah yeah the tities didn't have to
look so rough bro you didn't really have
to go hey my God they be doing the most
so and the lip injection is crazy about
the thing that's really disgusting about
it is because now that social media is
so um prant and you're seeing so many
people uh gravitating towards these
beauty trends cuz based off the people
that they're seeing online who are all
some of them don't even like to admit it
which is like I think it's espec if
you're a celebrity and you got something
done just admit it just admit it okay
especially when you got a huge following
you should be honest about that it's
like all the bodybuilders who like I'm
Natty I'm Natty you lying to youring
audience okay Ro what you did it the
rock it it it's not good because you're
setting unrealistic expectations people
are going to be frustrated because they
can't achieve what you achieve naturally
and they're going to feel the pressure
to do the things that you didn't want to
admit you didn't and they're going to
put themselves at risk they're going to
get it illegally they're going to pay
for the most runchy stuff because they
can't afford the good stuff stop there's
a lot of people who are complicit in
this whole thing men and women right who
are driving this [__] up so yeah I just
want to talk about that but just just
stop it you know like let's all just be
a little bit more honest it's okay we
all have that Vice in the we want
attention we want to be recognized guys
go to the gym yes it's for your mental
health it's for your you also like
looking good for the ladies you do you
like the idea of appealing to what that
standard is it's okay now go to the gym
just to lower my blood pressure that's
why sometimes I be respecting vain
people who are so open about their
vainness I I like when they're just like
you know what you want to out cuz when
it gets hot I like going to the beach
and taking off my shirt and seeing
people's reaction I appreciate that it's
honest at least is honest cuz so many
people are doing it for the same reason
have you ever have someone have you ever
had someone you take off your shirt and
they go o when it hits you it feels real
good yeah
ooh when it hits you o would tell me
what you're not lying and actually what
happened was I was I kept on being
around Wayne and them and at that time
you know Wayne he always talking about
big booties and all Wayne would have
like a new chick in the studio every
session so it was always a new a new big
booty creative support I just was around
them all the time and I was like sister
I was like the little sister with Wayne
and mac and all these boys you know J
Mills and G and all of them and all I
would hear them talking about is Big
Butts and I didn't feel Feel Complete or
good enough good as them as the other as
those girls because I'm like oh my God
you know this is what you're supposed to
look like in the in in our in the rap
culture and I don't look like that and
there's plenty of women who admit to
this stuff and I respect it it's
vulnerable it's honest I think it's said
that you have to go under a knife to
feel that kind of comfort but that's
real and and you know what the crazy
thing is it
works it's not so crazy crazy like
because people have this narrative in
their head yeah why you do that you know
you need to just love yourself here's a
[__] up thing in terms of career
opportunities and getting dudes this
[__] Works maybe not in the ways that
all these women want long term but it's
it works the satisfaction is uh quick
and so we're all complic creating a
society that rewards that you know so
how can I sit here and be like nobody
don't get surgery what I'm like look at
the results people are getting [__]
jobs getting dudes through their DMS all
the time like no no still wouldn't
recommend it I wouldn't recommend it no
I don't want people risking their lives
but like how they going to listen to me
over Real
Results you know what I'm saying it's
your body you do you but at the end of
the
day that's [__] up and uh yeah any
let's know what you guys think